[موسيقى]
احييكم اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه التي
نستهلوها كالعاده بابرز العناوين
اوكرانيا تقر بصعوبه الوضع في سوريا
بعد منعهم من العمل والتعليم طالبان تحضر
على النساء
وتمنعهن من الخروج من دون محرم
ايران تبرر قرار اعدام علي اكبر بانه ساهم
باغتيال العالم النووي محسن زادا
وبريطانيا تحذر من تنفيذ الاعدام
مدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه يزو ليبيا
لاول مره ويلتقي قائد الجيش خليفه حفتر
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا سنبدا من اوكرانيا
تحديدا من معارك الدائره حاليا في سوليدار
حيث تتضاربوا التصريحات حول السيطره
الروسيه الكامله عليها حتى الان في الوقت
الذي اكد فيه الكرملين ان الهجوم على
دونياسكي يتواصلوا بنجاح قالت اوكرانيا
وعلى لسان نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
جانا مليار ان الجيش يقاتل من اجل سوليدار
لكنه وصفه الوضع بالصعب على الارض في ظل
معارك هي الاشرس مع القوات الروسيه بحسب
وصفها واضافت ان الجنود الاوكرانيين
يقاتلون من دون توقف ورغم انها لن تشكل
نقطه تحول في الحرب الا ان سقوط سوليدار
في روسيا بعد اشهر من الدفاع الاوكراني
سيكون علامه فارغه في ساحه المعركه وسيوفر
للقوه الروسيه نقطه انطلاقا استراتيجيا لج
ها من اجل تطويق مدينه باخموتك وبحسب
ماليه فان موسكو تحشد قواتها في المدينه
حيث ارتفع عدد الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه
في المدينه من 250 الى 280 في اسبوع واحد
وقالت ان الوضع بات يشبه المذبحه ووفقا
لمسؤولين اخر ان القتال وصل ذروته على
الجبهه الشرقيه حيث يحاول الروس محاصره
القوات الاوكرانيه ياتي كل ذلك وسط مخاوف
من هجوم المحتمل من بيلاروسيا حليفه موسكو
القديمه شمال اوكرانيا هذا واكدت صحيفه
هورستريت جونيورز ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تتكبدت خسائر فادحه في المعارك قرب مخمد
وارجحت الصحيفه نقلا عن قائد عسكريا
اوكراني امكانيات التراجعي في حال استمرار
الوضعي على حاله
[موسيقى]
متابعه لما يجري على او في الوضع
الميدانيه ينضم الى المكياج الصحفي محمد
البابا من دونيتس مراسله العربيه رائد
الاخضر
سابدا معك من موسكو معي ايضا كاتيا طعمه
مراسله العربيه اهلا بكم معنا سابدا مع
رائد لنعرف من هو بالضبط ماذا يجري في
دونياسك اهم تطورات الميدانيه والعسكريه
هناك
ميسون بالفعل يعني مع
ارك عنف والقذف المتبادل ما بين الطرفين
هنا في دانيت في المدينه حيث تقصف المدينه
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر وكانها ضربات
انتقاميه للتقدم الروسي في محور سوليدار
بالفعل اضافت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات تسيطر قوات روسيا على المحور
الشمالي والشرقي من مدينه
وسط المدينه وفي مناطق متفرقه منها
الغربيه اما القوات باقنر فعل لسان قائدها
اكدت ان
ها سدود المدينه وانها قضت على اكثر
من 100 جندي اوكراني
جيوب المدينه رفضوا الاستسلام
بالفعل هناك معارك ضاريه في المحور الغربي
من المدينه حيث تشير بعض المصادر الى
اندادات اوكرانيه وصلت للقوات المتميزه في
غرب مدينه سلدار لكن الاله العسكريه
الروسيه ثقيله نتحدث عن المدافع
والصواريخ تقصد باستمرار همم همم
قد تصل الى ذلك المحور وتقصف قواعد عسكريه
او نقاط رياضيه للاتصال ما بين المقاتلين
على الجبهات وما بين الط اخر همم كقياده
اوكرانيه همم حتى الجانبيه
الزميل محمد البابا ايضا وجهه النظر
الاوكرانيه وما هي ابرز تصريحات من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه والقوات الاوكرانيه محمد
ماذا تتحدث القوات او الدفاع الاوكرانيه
عن موضوع سوليدار هل سقطت بيدروسيا ام بعد
يعني
حرس الحدود الاوكراني نشر بيان قبل حوالي
ساعه من الان اكد ان قوته تقوم بالرد
وتتقدم وبدات تشتبك عند الاتراك الشرقيه
والشماليه حيث دخلت واصبحت يعني يمكن
القول ان ان بلده اصبحت يعني متداخله هناك
مناطق تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه
وتنتشر فيها وايضا هناك مناطق استطاعت
القوات الروسيه
الدخول اليها هناك اشتباكات عنيفه الجيش
الاردني
وايضا من بلده كريسما هو بتلك البلديه
هناك تجمعات القوات القوات الجيش
الاوكراني بدا الجيش الاوكراني ونقل
المدفعيات يعني ثقيله من نوع هاوس الى ذلك
الى ذلك المحور لدار الخطوط القوات
الروسيه وكما قال ان
يعني نقبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
المعارك ضاريه جدا ويعني الجيش الاوكراني
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال يقاتل لا يزال
ان يعني ستبقى قوته وستبقى سوداربيات
الجيش الاوكراني ولكن كما كما ذكر رائد
الهجوم الكبير والعنيف وحتى يمكن القول
يعني بحسب شهود عيان من المناطق مجاوره
اصوات الاشتباكات والمدافع لا تتوقف ولا
لحظه في تلك المنطقه من الطرفين هناك يعني
قصص متبادل بشكل عنيف من الطرفين الجيش
الاوكراني يكثر خطوط الامداد للجيش الروسي
الجيش الروسي يكثر خطوط الامداد الجيش
الروسي كما يمكن ان هذه يعني هذه اشبه
معركه نهائيه بين الطرفين يفعل الطرفين
لتحقيق الانتصار على الاخر الجيش الروسي
وضع عقول ثقاله بحسب معلومات يعني ذكره
انه في تلك المحور تم حشر ما يزيد عن
30,000 جندي الهجوم على ظهره الشرقيه
والجنوبيه واللي احكام السيطره على
سوليدار والتقدم باتجاه بعض البلدات ل-
يعني اا محاصر اوكرانيه في مخمل ليبدا بعد
الهجوم
ساذهب الان الى موسكو مع زميلتنا كاتيا
كاتيا بالنسبه لتغيير في القياده العسكريه
الروسيه ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل وما هي
حياتياتها
مرحبا بك ميسون بالفعل كان قد اعلنا وزير
الدفاع الروسي تغييرات تغيير القاء القائد
العمليات العسكريه في العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا كان قد اعلن يوم امس
النائب سوريا
كان هو سيكون نائبا للقائد الذي هو سيقود
الان العمليات طبعا برر برر الدفاع
الروسيه هذا هذه التغيرات بانها تريد برفع
مستوى العمليات العسكريه هناك وانها
الحاجه الان هناك ان يكون على المستوى
الرفيع من القياده لاداره العمليات
وبالاخص خاصه بعد الدخول الى مدينه
سوليدار ومن بعدها طبعا كما تحدث البعد ان
هناك همم من بعد سيتم المحاوله الاستيلاء
على فخمه كامل لذلك برر بان الحاجه الان
والارض العمليات على الارض هي بحاجه الى
ان يكون على المستوى الرفيع من همم من اه
جاوب بالخص ان القائد الجديد هو الثاني
بالهرم العسكري في الروسيا وبحاجه للتنسيق
الكبير بين القوات الاربعه لنلاحظ ان طبعا
هذا التغيير هو الرابع في لقائد العمليات
العسكريه في ال- اا في اوكرانيا هو الشخص
الرابع سوري كان لم يكن لم يزل او لم ااه
يكون الا ثلاثه اشهر في هذا المنصب ولكن
لم يتم ابعاده بشكل كائن كامل هو سيكون
نائب لقائد العمليات هناك اربع جنينه
اربعه من الجنرالات او القاده الكبار
سيقودون الان العمليات هناك في اوكرانيا
ميسون سنعود الى زميلنا رائد الاخضر من
دونيس بالنسبه للوضع الانساني رائد كيف
يمكن ان نصفه وهل هناك حاله نزوح من
المناطق التي تتكثف فيها الاشتباكات
العسكريه
اشاره هامه جدا ميسون بالفعل هناك حملت
نزوح كبيره من مدينه دانيت حيث اقامتنا
حيث ان كثير من سكان هذه المدينه توجهوا
الى المناطق الجنوبيه حيث مريوبلنبات
الاكثر امنا لكن على
الحراس فان ااه مسؤوليه حقوق الانسان عند
الجانب الروسي ومسؤولي حقوق
الانسان الاجانب الاوكراني يتواصلون
ويقرون
باجراء عمليات تبديل جديده في كل يومين
فلا تتم عمليه تبديل
للاسرى من المتوقع في اليومين القادمين ان
تكون هناك ايضا عمليه جديده لاستبدال
الاسرى بين الطرفين ك
ما ان الفتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين
العالقين في المناطق الساخنه مثل سوليطار
احد من لان باقي هي همم الهدف الرئيس
للقوات الرئيسيه حيث انها اصبحت
تقريبا شبه متوقع من الناحيه ال ال
الشماليه والشرقيه واا يعني يرى الجيش
الروسي
بانه سيتقدم نحو ال بلدات في افراح مدينه
باكو من اجل بحر الجيش الاوكراني الى
الخلف من الناحيه الغربيه
الصوت من المصدر اشكر زميلنا رائد الاخضر
من دونياسكا الصحفي محمد البابا من كاف
وزميلتنا كاتيا تومي مراسلت العربيه من
موسكو شكرا لكم
عدد من المسؤولين الروس زاروا بيلاروسيا
لتفقد استعدادها للقتال واضافت الدفاع
الروسيه ان القائد العام للقوات البريه
الروسيه
لتفقد استعدادات القوات المشتركه للقتال
هذا واظهرت الصور واستهداف القصف الروسيه
مستشفى للولاده في مدينه خيرسون
الاوكرانيه
في فيينا ان المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفايل جروسي سيزور اوكرانيا
الاسبوع المقبل لبحث وضعي محطه الزبورد
فاعل يا نوف عبر حسابه على تويتر
مع السلطات الاوكرانيه مبادراته بشان
انشائي منطقه امان النووي حول محطه
النوويه واتبادلت موسكو
المحطه الاكبر في اوروبا ضمن العمليه
العسكريه التي تشونها روسيا على اوكرانيا
منذ اواخر فبراير شباط الماضي
اعلن رئيس البولندي اندري دوده خلال زياره
الى اوكرانيا ان بلاده مستعده لان تسود
كاف بدبابه ثقيله متطوره من نوع اليوبارد
2 ياتي ذلك بعد اشهر من المطالبات
الاوكرانيه للدول الاوروبيه لتحديث
اسطولها العسكري مع اشتداد المعارك على
الارض
اوكرانيا
اوروبا
المانيه الصنع متوفره ايضا في اسبانيا
وفنلندا وهولندا
المانيا كثيرا ممتنعت عن الموافقه على
التبرع بها لكن ووفقا للرئيس البولندي
اعاده برلين النظر في هذه المساله
بالتوازي تخطط بريطانيا لارسال عشر دبابات
تشالنجر الاوكرانيا
دبابات ليبرتو يبلغ وزنها 69 طنا تضم
مدفعا عيار 120 م
دبابه تشالنجر 71 طنا مسلحه بمدفع بنادق
من عيار 120 ملم
ليبرتو وتشالنجر من افضل الدبابات في
العالم
يتوقع ان ترسل فرنسا مركبات استطلاع اي ام
اكس 10 لاوكرانيا
وهي مركبه قتاليه تعرف ايضا بمدمر
الدبابات
العربيه بيان سعوديين مصري يرفض اي
محاولات لاطراف اقليميه بالتدخل في شؤون
الدول العربيه اذن هذا البيان المصري
السعودي يرفض اي محاولات لاطراف اقليميه
بالتدخل في شؤون الدول العربيه نتابع الان
ايضا هذه النشره في ظل ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه والمواد الاستهلاكيه وزياده التضخم
طالب البرلمان الاوروبي باجراء استطلاع
راي حول الضغوط الاجتماعيه التي يواجهها
سكان القاره الاوروبيه والتي اظهرت زياده
القلق لدى الاوروبيين في مختلف مناحي
الحياه متابعه
[موسيقى]
في نشرتينا نتابع بعد الفاصل
عمليه فصل الصياميه العراقيه تتواصل في
الرياض واخر المراحل تقترب من نهايتها
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل النشره من
افغانستان حيث دعى المتحدث وباسم الطالبان
ذبحنا مجاهد المجتمع الدولي
بمواصله التعاون مع حكومه بلاده وان يكف
ان تدخل في شؤون الداخليه مجاهد كذا انا
حكومه طالبان تتفهموا قلق المجتمع الدولي
من قرار تعليم المراه لكنه دعاهم الى
الاستمرار بتقديم المساعدات لبلادته
[موسيقى]
بعد اغلاق ابواب المدارس والجامعات امام
الفتيات وتعليق عمل النساء في المنظمات
غير الحكوميه تضيق حركه طالبان ايضا
المساحه المتاحه امام النساء حيث امر حاكم
اقليم غور الواقع وسط البلاد مؤخرا مقاتلي
الحركه بمنع النساء من الخروج من منازل
لهن في المدينه من دون محرم وقالت مصادر
في اقليم جار لصحيفه افغانيه محليه ان
احمد شا- حاكم طالبان في الاقليم عبر عن
غضبه من تعليق بعض المنظمات الاجنبيه
لاعمالها بسبب القرارات الاخيره ضد النساء
وقال ان المؤسسات الاجنبيه هي غير صادقه
مع شعب افغانستان حيث دانا ما وصفه
باستخدام ذريعه لهجوم الغرب على بلاده هذا
وامر شاهد بعدم السماح للمراه بالتجول في
شوارع المدينه دون محرم من الان فصاعدا
واوجهها بتكثيف الدوريات في المدينه
لتوقيف النساء المخ كما نقلت صحيفه محليه
عن سيده بالمدينه تشتكي من القيود
المتزايده التي تفرضها حركه طالبان قولها
انها علمت بالقرار من صاحب احد المتاجر
التي دعاها للتسوق سريعا والعوده للمنزل
من دون ان تراها دوريات طالبان الاسواق
باتت خاليه من النساء فجاه بعد قرار منع
تجوالهن من دون محرم وهو ما اعتبرته نشطه
افغانيات انتهاكا لحقوق الانسان
ويزيد من القيود المفروضه عن المراه
الافغانيه من دون وجه حقا مازلنا في شان
الافغان الثاني حيث يبرر نائب المتحدث
باسم الحركه الطالبان بلال كريم قرار
الاماره في افغانستان منع تعليم المراه في
الجامعه بانه من واجبها تنظيم شؤون
التعليم والتنميه في البلاد وفقا لاحكام
الشارع وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال ان
النظام وطالبان منح المراه حقوقا لم تكن
موجوده في السابق
خير يوقفنا
ذكرنا ان الامارات الاسلاميه تتكون من
علماء وطلاب يهتمون بالعلوم والتربيه
والتعليم اكثر من اي فئه اخرى والاماره لا
تعارض تعليم اي شخص باي شكل من الاشكال
ولكنها مسؤوله عن تنظيم المراحل التربويه
والتعليميه وكل ما يتعلق بذلك فهي مسؤوله
وترى ان من واجبها ان يكون ذلك وفقا
لاحكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه اليوم
السادسه عشر بتوقيت جرينتش السابعه مساء
بتوقيت السعوديه ودائما على العربيه
تتواصلوا في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
عمليه فصل التوام السيامي العراقيه عمر
وعلي ووفقا لمراسل العربيه فان العمليه
تجري الان في مراحلها الاخيره وفي المرحله
الخامسه فعليا حيث تمت عمليه الفصل
المبدئيا رئيس الفريق التبيد دكتور عبد
الله الربيعه اكد العربيه ان حاله التوام
مستقره
لمعرفه اين وصلت هذه العمليه ينضم الينا
من مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال
في وزاره الحرس الوطني بالرياض مراسل
العربيه هاني صفيان هاني اهلا بك معنا
وصلنا الى المرحله الخامسه متى ستنتهي
وكيف هي حال الوالدين اصبح بامكاننا القول
الولدين لانه الفصل جرب المرحله
التي كانت سبقت هذا الموضوع
الصحيح نعم ميسون الان الطفلين عمر وعلي
همم يقوم مع الطاقم الطبي بعمليه الترميم
وايضا المرحله او انتهاء المرحله الخامسه
للاستعداد في المرحله السادسه لدينا همم
لعمر والاخر اللي عليه وكمان نشاهد الطاقه
الطبيه الان يقوم بالاشراف والتاكد ايضا
من همم استقرار حالتهما وكذلك ايضا وضعهما
الصحي سوف يكون معي ضيفي الدكتور سعد
المهرج وهو مدير عام الشؤون الطبيه في
وزاره الحرس الوطني واستشاري عظام الاطفال
مرحبا بك دكتور نتحدث عن المراحل الاخيره
للمرحله الخامسه التي سوف تبدا بعدها
المرحله ايضا المرحله السادسه
لتوجيهات خادم الحرمين الشريفين
والسموحه ومتابعه وزير الحرس الوطني همم
بدات العمليه صباح الباكر والان في
المرحله الخامسه وهي عمليات الترميم
للجروح والانسجه والحمد لله العمليه في
اكمل وجه وحاله الطفل المطمئنه طفلين
مطمنه عمر وعلي وبعد ان شاء الله تقريبا
نص ساعه هيبدا عمليه الترميم النهائي
للجلد والقفل ثم المرحله الاخيره عمليه
الغيار المرحله السادسه كيف سوف تتمم وما
هي المده المحدده
عمليه الترميم والانسجه والقفل الجلد تاخذ
تقريبا ساعه الا ساعه ونصف وبعدين العمليه
الاخيره اللي هي عمليه الغيار وايضا
انتقال الاطفال الى العنايه الفائقه او
الى العنايه المركزه ان شاء الله
بس نتحدث اليوم عن الخدمات اللوجستيه التي
يقدمها مستشفى الحرس الوطني هنا في او
مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي في وزاره
الحرس الوطني كيف هيئت
لمكانا مناسبا وملائما لعمليات فصل
التوائم سواء لهذه الحاله او الحالات ال
53 التي سبقت الحاله هذه وهي رقم 54 نعم
تاريخ العمليات فصل التوائم طبعا من 30
سنه تقريبا وهذه كما ذكرت يعني هذه
العمليه رقم 54 وجميعا ما شاء الله همم
تكللت بالنجاح طبعا
القياده الرشيده والحكومه الرشيده ما قصرت
يعني حقيقه في استثمار في
المواطن السعودي من جراحين ومن الرياضات
وخدمات فالان هذه النتائج جميع الجراحين
السعوديين والتمريض كذلك وجميع الخدمات
المقدمه وكذلك الاجهزه العاليه والتقنيه
العاليه فالحمد لله رب العالمين الان اصبح
هذه النتائج الغرس كان يعني جميله
والنتائج ان شاء الله جميله ايضا شكرا لك
دكتور قاعد يعطيك الف عافيه اذا ان نقوم
الان برصد هذه اللحظات الاخيره وهي
العمليات المرحله الاخيره لعمليات الترميم
كما تحدث الدكتور سعد لعمر وعلي وكذلك
نشاهد الطاقم الطبيه الذي يقوم بعمليه
الفصل طبعا الدكتور عبدالله الربيعه
القائد الفريق الطبي ل- اا لفصل التوام
وكذلك بوجود الكادر الطبي يقومون بالاشراف
والاتمام اللازم المرحله الرابعه لانها هي
كانت المرحله الحساسه وهي الصعبه كما ذكر
الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه لان تتم فيها
عمليه فصل الكبد وكذلك قناه الصفراويه
وكذلك عمليات ال- ال- ال- الفصل الاول
لعمر وعلي وتم بذلك بنجاح وشاهدنا على
شاشه العربيه من خلال النشرات الماضيه كيف
تمت والان في انتظار في مرحله السادسه
وسوف يتوقع انتهاء هذه العمليه كامله في
تمام الساعه قد يساوي النصف الى السابعه
مساء بتوقيت المحلي السعودي
طلعنا على نتائج هذه المرحله الاخيره
والعمليه الاخيره وطبعا مباركه لاهل
الطفلين عمر وعلي همم على فصلهما وطبعا
نتمنى ان نتكلم المرحله الاخيره ايضا
بالنجاح كالمراحل السابقه شكرا لك هاني
الصياد من المستشفى التخصصي مستشفى الملك
عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال في وزاره الحرس
الوطني في الرياض
كشف موقع اكسس الاخباريه عن ازمات نقل
تاريخيه وسلسله من الانهيارات في قطاع
النقل الجوي والسكك الحديديه في امريكا
خلال اول عامين منطقه
وزير النقل هذا بعد ان دفع وزير النقل
الامريكيه عن قرار اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه بوقف اقلاع الرحلات الجويه على
مستوى الولايات المتحده بعد انقطاع في
النظام السلامه ووفق موقع اكسس الاخباريه
ساعه الجمهوريون الى
وضعته
النقل بينما يقول الديمقراطيون ان قيادته
للازمه تثبت قوته السياسيه وبان عدم وجود
دائم لاداره الطيران الفيدراليه قد تطلب
من
يتولى دورا اكثر مواجهه للجمهور
في غضون ذلك قالت كارينا السكريتير
الصحفيه للبيت الابيض ان سلامه المسافر
الامريكيه اولويه لدى الحكومه الامريكيه
مشدده ان اداره الطيران فيدراليه ستتقدم
بشفافيه لشرح سبب تعطل حركه الملاحه
الجويه في جميع انحاء البلاد
الفيدراليه ودائره النقل في ممارسه
الشفافيه بشان سبب عطل الطيران ولضمان عدم
حدوث عطل بهذا الحجم مره اخرى لذا اتحدث
بصدق عندما اقول ان تركيزنا الاول هو
تامين سلامه الامريكيين المسافرين والتاكد
من ان مثل هذا الحدث لن يحدث مره اخرى
من مطار
مراسل العربيه حسين اهلا بك معنا كيف تبدو
حركات الطيران في هذه اللحظات بعدها هذا
العطل الذي اثار جدلا كبيرا منذ الامس
تحيه لك يا ميسون الحركه اليوم صراحه
عاديه لا يوجد الكثير من
الغاء الرحلات او
من ديرها تم التعامل بشكل فعال على ما
يبدو البارحه خلال ساعات الليل بعد جدولا
الرحلات التي
بسببها العطله الذي كان سببه احد الملفات
التالفه في قاعده البيانات لنظام همم ما
شاهدناه اليوم حركه عاديه الثالثه همم
الامور تسير حتى الان بشكل طبيعي لا نعرف
سيتم همم سيكون هناك استحام بعد الظهر او
مشكله بعد الظهر بسبب تاخير رحلات من
البارحه سننتظر في في هذا المطار لنرى ان
كان ذلك سيحدث طبعا طبعا هناك همم سياسيه
على ما جرى وزير النقل الان همم يتعرض
لنقضي كبير واداره الرئيس انت بتعرض لنقل
كبير لا سيما ان الرئيس بايدا روج لنفسه
بانه رئيس اصلاح البونيه تحتيها هو في شهر
نوفمبر عام 2021 وقع على مشروع او قانون
البنيه التحتيه الذي
فوض او اعطى ل همم
هيئه او اداره الطيران الامريكي مليار
دولار من اجل اصلاحها ومن اجل المعدات
وتطوير المعدات والاجهزه كذلك خصص اربعه
مليارات دولار لاعاده تطوير المطارات
والبني تحتيها للمطارات والان يحدث ما
يحدث الجمهوريون همم يحاولون استغلال اي
نقطه
ينتقدوه وينتقدوا مشوعه همم اعاده تحديث
الذي التي يرون بها جزء منهم طبعا ليس
جميعا بها انفاق كبير رغم ان هذا المشروع
تم بموافقه الحزبين في مجلس الشيوخ لكن
هناك منتقدون له كثيرون نسيمه من
الجمهوريين الذين يعتبرون ان الاداره تصرف
اموال كثيره
حسين بموضوع التحقيقات من هي الجهات التي
تقوم بتحقيقات ما حصل البارحه هل ما زال
استبعاد الهجوم السبيرانيه اا متصدرا لانه
بالامس معظم المؤسسات
الدستوريه والامنيه في اا الولايات
المتحده استبعدت موضوع
الهجوم السبراني هل مازال هذا الاستبعاد
قائما من يقوم اليوم بالتحقيقات هل وزاره
النقل هيئه الطيران ماذا عن الكونجرس ما
هي ابرز التصريحات التي قدمها بعد هذا
الانقطاع بالامس وهذا العطل الفني
ميسون اداره الطيران الفدرالي هي تابعه
لوزاره النقل لذلك الوزاره والادارهما من
تقومان
بتحقيق الذي اسفر حتى الان عن ارتفاعات
اللي هي همم الاحتماليه او فرضيه موجوده
عمل اعدائي سيبراني ادى الى التلف هذا
الملف ااه بالنسبه
دعوات تتزايد من اجل جلسات استماع للتحقيق
بما جرى همم ناسيه مع ان الكونجرس كان دعا
سابقا ايضا الى جلسات استماع بما يخص شركه
طيران ااه صوت وتعويضاتها للمسافرين الان
همم تتزيد الدعوات ايضا من الجمهوريين
لتعيين رئيس لاداره الطيران الى هذه
الاداره حتى همم هذه الاداره الطيران يعني
الفيدرالي ليس على راسها لا يوجد على
راسها رئيس لذلك هناك دعوات من همم مجلس
الشيوخ ومن مجلس النواب ولا سيما من
الجمهوريين لتعيين رئيس يقولون انه يجب ان
يكون على همم معرفه الطيران طبعا همم
واشنطن وهو كان مدير مطار
اذا التنفيذي لمطار يكون رئيس اداره
الطيران الفدرالي ولكن حتى الان لم لم
تعقد جلسه استماع له في الكونغرس من اجل
تثبيت هذا الترشيح وهذا التعيين همم دعوات
التزايده الجمهوريه يعتبرون ان ما جرى فشل
يعتبرون ان ما جرى يجب يتحمل يتحمل
مسؤوليته همم وزير النقل بجاج همم لانه هو
همم اصلا اخذ على عقيقه ما يجرب قال لنا
هذه المراه همم هيئه الطيران همم اداره
طيران هي التي مسؤول عن العطل عن تحقيقات
ما زالت جاريه طبعا همم ولكن كما تفضلت
حتى الان هناك استبعاد ل- فرضيه وجود هجوم
صيدليه همم
هذه التحقيقات وما هي النتائج التي يمكن
ان تصل اليها من مطار رونالديفن شكرا لك
حسين العربي
في نشره نتابع بعد الفاصل بعد خسائر
مالكها ايلون ماسك تويتر تدرس طبيعه اسماء
المستخدمين في مزاد
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت وكالات الانباء
الايرانيه الرسميه
زاد في عام 2020 في غضون ذلك قالت عائلته
اكبر ان السلطات الايرانيه تستعد لاعدامه
وقالت زوجه اكبري ان احد المسؤولين طلب
من اجل اللقاء الاخير كما طلبت بريطانيا
ايران بوقفه تنفيذي حكم الاعدام بحق اكبر
وقالت انه وجود واسع سياسيه كما من المقرر
ان يناقشها البرلمان البريطاني اليوم
الوضع في ايران وقمع الاحتجاجات المستمره
لمعرفه المزيد حول هذه النقشات التي ستحصل
اليوم ينضم الي من لندن مراسل العربيه
مصطفى زارو مصطفى اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا
من تفاصيل حول هذه الجلسه هل بدات
بالانعقاد وابرز الملفات التي ستكون حاضره
بخصوص ايران اليوم
الجلسه يعني نتزال يعني جاريه داخل مجلس
قبه البرلمان هناك ما يقال من ثلاث ساعات
والمناقشات مستمره بين مختلف النوبه ومن
مختلف الحساب يتحدثون عن السياسات ايران
القمعيه
والاعتداءات التي يتعرض لها المتظاهرون
هناك من قبل الشرطه همم الشرطه الايرانيه
وهناك ايضا في نفس الوقت مطالب باتخاذ
المزيد من الاجراءات ضد النظام الايراني
في ظل همم في ظل هذه الممارسات
القمعيه التي تنتجها النظام الايراني بحق
المتظاهرين بشكل سلمي هناك ايضا مطالبه من
هؤلاء
همم ليتم ادراج الحرس الثوري على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه المحظوره في المملكه
المتحده
لكن لا تزال المناقشات مستمره وحاليا يرد
احد وزراء همم الخارجيه البريطانيه على
بعض استفسارات هؤلاء النواه في هذه الجلسه
الاستثنائيه التي ربما ستمتد الى همم
ساعتين او ثلاث ساعات من من الان نتوقع
ايضا بان ترفع
هؤلاء النواب التوصيه الى الحكومه
باتخاذها المزيد من الاجراءات وعلى راس
هذه الاجراءات حضر الحرس الثوري وهذا يعني
اذا ما تمت فعلا اتخاذ هذا قرار بحسب
النواب يقولون بانه يجب على بريطانيا ان
تتخذ يعني قرارا همم يتماشى مع مع قامت به
السلطات الامريكيه والكنديه بحضر الحرس
الثوري همم ولكن بالطبع الحكومه يعني تدرس
كل هذه الخيارات كان هناك سؤال همم تقريبا
قبل اسبوع على
رئيس الوزراء رئيس السودان ولكن قال له لن
يدخل في اي تفاصيل تتعلق بمناقشه هكذا
ودراسه ملف حظر وبالتالي هذه المناقشه
اليوم ستزيد الضغط على الحكومه لاتخادي
قرار الممثل في واش وايضا في كندا طب
مصطفى بخصوص علي رضا اكبري وتنفيذ حكم
الاعدام فيه استنكرت بريطانيا من هذا
الموضوع وطالبات ايران بعدم تنفيذ هذه
العقوبه هل هناك من تفاصيل اكثر هل هناك
من معلومات حول جهود بريطانيا
لعدم تنفيذ حكم الاعدام علي رضا اكبر
حقيقه يعني المعلومات يعني صحيحه جدا عدا
البيان الصحفي الذي اصدرته وزاره الخارجيه
تحث فيها النظام الايراني بعدم الاقدام
على اعدام علي رضا اكبر بعد ان وجدته
محكمه تابعه للحرسانيه انه مدان في عمليات
تجسس لصالح الاستخبارات الخارجيه
البريطانيه ولكن همم بريطانيا بالتاكيد
لها قنوات لمتابعه هكذا خصوصا بانها هناك
اكثر من شخصيه تحمل جنسيه مزدوجه تحت ال-
ال- السجن او في السجون الايرانيه
وبالتالي همم ربما هناك يعني قنوات اتصال
تجري في محاوله في ايجاد يعني ربما او حتى
الضغط على النظام الايراني الذي يحاول ان
يحاول ان يؤثر على سياسته الخارجيه من
خلال استخدام همم الجنسيه المزدوجه ليس
البريطانيا حسب ايضا جنسيات اخرى مثل
شهيدنا في فرنسا وايضا ااا في في الولايات
المتحده لا ندري ان فعلا يعني همم لدى
المملكه المتحده اي السيارات اخرى للتاثير
ولكن هناك مناسبه من قبل النواب ل- اا
يعني التنسيق مع شركاء الدولي لفرض المزيد
من العقوبات على ان النظام الايراني وخاصه
في ما يتعلق همم فيما يتعلق يعني همم ما
يتعلق بحقوق المراه التي شيدت العديد من
الحساسات في ايران بسبب يعني النظام
الايراني
المتساقط عليك يعطيك العافيه شكرا لك
مصطفى زاروه من لندن مراسل العربيه
هو بينما تتواصل التحضيرات العالميه بشان
خطر اعدام المتظاهرين في ايران تشير
تقارير الحقوقيه الى استمرار الممارسات
القمعيه للنظام بما في ذلك اختطاف الاطفال
اصدار واحكام قاسيه بحق المحتاجين
بالاضافه الى تعرض المتظاهرين الماسونيين
للتعذيب كما ايضا استهدف القمع بشكل رئيسي
لطلاب الذين شكلوا نواه للاحتجاجات على
مدى الاشهر الماضيه حيث افاده المجلس
التنسيقي للنقابات المعلمين باعتقال
الطالب مواعيد حسين البالغ من العمر 17
الى ان المحكمه الثوريه في محافظه ساري
استدعت 24 طالبا من جامعه
من بينهم سته عشر طالبا تم استدعائهم في
يوم واحد
شملت حملات القمعي اساتذه ايضا التي كان
اخرهم زاهد سليمان بحسب ما افادت نقابه
المعلمين حيث اعتقل سليمان في الديوان
دراه وان نقل مكان مجهول ايضا الصحفيون لم
يسلموا من حملات القمع فنشلت نقابه
الصحافه قائمه بالمعتقلين الذين بلغوا 30
صحافيا مؤكده انهم مازالوا
رهن الاحتجاج منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات
زار رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه ويليامبرز ليبيا لاول مره
والثقافه طرابلس قائد الجيش الليبي خليفه
حفتر حيث بحث مع حفتر الشؤون المشتركه كما
التقى رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميدبا
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه انه قد يلتقي
بنظيره السوريه فيصل المقداد في اوائل
فبراير النافيه يعني التقارير التي تفيد
بانهما قد يجتمعان الاسبوع المقبل مضيفا
بانه هناك قلنا من قبل من قبل هناك بعض
المقترحات بشان لقاء الاسبوع المقبل لكنه
لا يناسبنا
اعلن وزير الدفاع الامريكيه واشنطن
الولايات المتحده واليابان اتفقت اعلى انا
معاهده الدفاع المشتركه المبرمه بينهما
تشمل ايضا الهجمات التي تتم عبر الفضاء في
خطوه تاتي في خدم تزايد القدرات الصينيه
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه ياتي ذلك في مطالب
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارج الصينيه بان لا
يؤثر هذا الاتفاق على الاستقرار الاقليميه
حراره تصعيد شرقي اسيا لا تقل عن حرب
ساخنه تؤجج الوضع وتخلق نقاط تحولا في دول
المنطقه في اليابان التي يحضر دسترها
السلمي تكوين جيشا حقيقي
وتطوير القدرات العسكريه مع الولايات
المتحده لمواجهه تهديدات الصين وكوريا
الشماليه
وجود امريكيون في المنطقه ليس بالجديد اذ
تتواجد قواعد استراتيجيه الرئيسيه وهي
مخصصه للتمركز وقواعد العمليات الاماميه
لتوفير الدعم والحمايه للقواعد
الاستراتيجيه بالاضافه الى مواقع التعاون
الامني وهي القواعد الجويه والبحريه
التابعه للحلفاء
الاجتماعات الثنائيه بين واشنطن تدور حول
التحدي الاستراتيجي الاكبر كما اتفق عليه
الطرفان وهي الصين التعاون الثنائي طال
الفضاء ليتم تم تمديد الشروط معاهده
الدفاع المشترك وتشمل الفضاء والاستعداد
للتصدي لاي هجوم عبره
الخامسه من المعاهده ما يعني ان اي هجوم
على اي من البلدين هجوم على الاخر
نحن نعمل على تعليق تعاوننا عبر كل
المجالات الفضاء الخارجي مهم لامن تحالفنا
وازدهاره الهجمات على الفضاء او منه تمثل
تحديا واضحه
لا يشبه شيئا من النهج الدفاع والسلمي
الذي لطالما اتبعته اليابان لتزيد ميزانيه
الدفاع خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله وتعزز
قدره الرد ليس فقط بالدفاع بل بالهجوم
ايضا اذا عمر العربيه صدر بيان السعوديه
مصري مشترك بعد حضور وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ونظيره
المصري سنه شكري اجتماعا لجنه المتابعه
والتشاوريه السياسيه على المستوى الوزريه
ورفض البيان اي محاولات لاطراف الاقليميه
بالتدخل بشؤون الدول العربيه وتهديد
استقرار المصالح الشعوب المنطقه البيان
اكد ان واستقرار السودان جزء لا يتجزء من
الامن السعودي المصري واكد على دعم
البلدين لحل النبيل برعايه المتحده مشددا
على ضروره وقف التدخلات الخارجيه في
الشؤون الليبيه البيان السعوديه المصريه
شدد على ضروره احترام ايران الالتزاماتها
النوويه بشكل كامل كما ادانت السعوديه
ومصر ايام محاوله للمساس بامن وسلامه
الملاحات في الممرات المائيه
قالت مصادر مطلعه ان شركه التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر تبحث وامكانيه طبيعيه
اسماء المستخدمين الفريده من خلال
المسادات عبر الانترنت لزياده ارادتها
وقالت المصادر لصحيفه نيويورك تايمزا
الامريكيه ان تويتر تدرس طبيعه اسماء
المستخدمين كاش الجزء من محاولات مالكها
الجديد الملياردير لهم ماسك احياء اعمال
الشركه كما نقلت وكاله الانباء عن مصادر
انه هو لم يتضح حتى الان ما اذا كان هذا
المشروع سيكتمل ام سيتم تراجع عنه وما اذا
كان سيشمل كل اسماء المستخدمين او فقط
مجموعه محدده
انت هتنشره الخامسه دائما لمتابعه ملفات
العربيه والمزيد من الاخبار مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب وطبعا
موقع العربيه دوت نت اترككم في امان الله
[موسيقى]